hi everyone welcome to another q a about
science and technology for kids and
others
um I thought uh I'm trying to change up
a little bit the way that I'm doing
these things uh on Fridays I'm now
alternating between uh General q a about
science and technology for kids and
others and Q a about future of Science
and Technology on Alternate weeks this
week is a is a general q a
um I also thought this week maybe I
would encourage people to ask questions
that sort of seem simple but which maybe
they're not sure they know the answers
to and I'll try and try and address them
I see an interesting one here from
Parker that says is it possible to
create more universe
that's an interesting and kind of
complicated question
so
actually relates a lot to work that I've
done on fundamental theories of physics
and uh well let's start off with some
basics
so normally kind of the background for
what's happening in the universe is that
there's space there's there's something
where you can put things here or there
sort of in the universe and the
traditional View
that up until about a hundred and
something years ago people sort of
imagined that space was just this
completely background thing that had no
character of its own it was just you put
things here you put things there and uh
it was just something where you could do
geometry in space and space was just
this pure static background then with
Einstein's general theory of relativity
that came out in 1915 there was kind of
the idea that it was that one should
think about space as having some
potential structure for example being
curved for example that a massive object
could curve space and that that was a
way of accounting for the presence of
gravity
and so that was sort of a place where it
started to look like there was something
about space that wasn't just this pure
background static thing it was something
where there was some level of kind of uh
uh kind of character to space where it
wasn't like every piece of space
everywhere in the universe is the same
there could be a piece of space that was
curved as a result of the presence of
mass that and that curvature would lead
to the force of gravity and so on and
roughly why that happens is in normally
if you say and this is something that uh
was kind of thought about from the time
of Newton in the late 1600s this
Newton's first law that if you just
start something going in some direction
and you don't operate on it with any
Force you just let it go then it will go
in a straight line and uh that was by
the way at the time in Newton's time
that was a not a trivial hypothesis to
make because in Newton's time one didn't
have uh it was the the you know if you
push something on the ground it was just
going to come to a halt because there
was going to be friction and so on you
didn't have nice you know air hockey
tables that people used to to
demonstrate this stuff now with very low
friction and so on I mean I suspect
actually in Newton's time I think it was
a time soon after at least the little
Ice Age so I think even kind of where
Newton lived probably the rivers were
frozen much of the time so so maybe he
did have the analog of the of the air
hockey table maybe he could uh I
actually don't know maybe he could have
sort of slid things around on the on
these frozen rivers and and knowing that
there was I had a notion of uh
um a lack of um uh a lack of kind of um
uh frictional force actually it's a good
good history history footnote thing to
look up
um since the um I know the central
England temperature
um measurement I think was started in
1650 so it must have covered the time
it's the longest running kind of
measurement of of temperatures uh in in
on the earth that exists and so that
must cover the time of Newton so anyway
something to look up but um in any case
back to back to this so so in sort of
the Newton's idea of how mechanics
worked things that weren't acted on by a
force were just going straight lines and
for example light
you shine a laser somewhere it just kind
of goes in a straight line but more
precisely you can think of it as going
from where it starts to where it ends by
the shortest path and in normal geometry
you know you take a piece of string you
pull on the ends the string will go
straight the shortest path between two
points is a straight line
however if the this the if if you're on
a curved space so for example instead of
the string just being out in the air so
to speak it's on the surface of uh of a
sphere let's say the string doesn't get
to go in a purely straight line because
it's following the surface of the sphere
but it gets to go on a great circle in
the case of the sphere gets to go on a
path that happens to be curved there if
you imagine that the that you the thing
is on kind of a table that has a
depression in the middle then the
shortest paths will end up being
deformed by the presence of that
depression and then so that's kind of
Einstein's idea of how things work in in
physical space is that the the space is
curved as a result of the presence of of
mass and the presence of that curvature
means that the shortest path between two
points are no longer straight lines
they're instead deflected lines that are
deflected and that deflection turns out
to correspond to the reflection
associated with gravity so that was kind
of the the idea of uh Einstein's idea so
uh one of the things that that came up
in the equations that Einstein derived
for the relationship between curvature
and mass and so on was the prediction
that the Universe should expand and that
the uh that the sort of in some sense
the total amount of space the total
distance by amount of space we can say
how long does it take to go from here to
there that the time it would take to go
all the way across the universe or to go
a quarter of the way across the universe
or something would be longer later on
than it was earlier in the history of
the universe so in other words in that
that's the sense in which the universe
will be expanding
so uh Einstein sort of saw that that was
what the equations implied so that
couldn't possibly be right you know we
know the universe isn't expanding he
said look it's not expanding it kind of
reminds one of the the pre-copernicus
kind of view of look we know the Earth
isn't moving around the sun we know the
Earth is stationary because we're here
standing on it so to speak but Einstein
made the same mistake he always
characterized it as his biggest science
mistake and so he added a term to his
equations the so-called cosmological
term which would sort of uh with which
would kind of go against this this force
of expansion that was otherwise
predicted okay well it turns out it was
a mistake and a chap called Edwin Hubble
about
um oh less than 10 years later observed
the expansion of the universe so in
other words what that means is that in
some sense the space is expanding there
is you could say in Einstein's view of
things there is more space because it
takes longer to go some percentage of
the way across the universe later in the
history of the universe than earlier in
the history of the universe now it can
get kind of complicated because in the
you know if you're one second after the
beginning of the universe and you say
well gosh you can get all the way across
the universe and it's going to take you
three seconds well you didn't have three
seconds to get all the way across the
universe and the one second since the
universe started so to speak so you know
the expansion of the universe in some
sense is not chaseable that's a general
feature of it it doesn't depending on
its details it can end up sort of not
being traceable by any uh you know by
any by anything that was was sort of
trying to get to the edge of the
universe by the time you get there it's
expanded okay so in the usual sort of
view of of how space works in the
traditional View and that I would say
the the uh the classic view the
classical view of how space works it is
this idea that the Universe expands the
distance between things gets larger and
in some sense space is expanding so you
could say there's more Universe there
um there's more sort of distance in
space available
okay but but in that picture of things
there is a description of things like
curvature in space but space isn't
really a thing space is just this sort
of background that has certain
characteristics but it's not sort of in
and of itself a thing now it can have
can have very violent characteristics
like it can form event Horizons around
black holes it can be uh it can be sort
of uh it can be very distorted but it's
still just a background
now in our model of physics space really
does become a thing
space is no longer just a background
that you put things in space is an
actual structure of its own it's some
kind of graph where there are just
points kind of atoms of space and there
are connections between those atoms of
space that form a giant Network and
there is nothing in the universe other
than that Network there's no background
it's not like the network is is put into
something all you know about the
universe is there's this network and
it's atoms of space that are related to
each other that are effectively
connected to each other okay so in that
picture the universe consists of some
number of atoms of space maybe it's you
know a one with 400 zeros after 10 to
the 400
um atoms of space that make up our
universe
and in that case there's kind of that's
the universe and everything in it so
that big network has to represent both
the thing we call space
and all the things like particles like
electrons and photons and all those
kinds of things that exist in space and
the picture is that there's this network
and it's kind of always bubbling around
it's always rewriting itself it's always
updating itself it has a certain a
certain uh there's all this activity in
it and that the fact that there's
activity is the reason that one part of
space can sort of communicate with
another part because there's activity
here and that's connected to activity
that activity in in sort of in trains
activity a little bit over and that in
trans activity further over and so on
and then if you let the activity run for
a little while a certain amount of time
then you will the thing that is over
here will eventually be able to affect
the thing that's over here and that's
kind of what knits together some
coherent structure of space if it wasn't
for that activity there'd be just all
these separate atoms of space they would
have no relationship to each other they
would have no communication between each
other there wouldn't be this thing that
we can think of as this kind of
background of space and when it comes in
our models to things like particles we
imagine that those are certain sort of
robust features of this network that
represents the structure of space much
like an analogy I tend to use in a fluid
like water we know there's a bunch of
molecules bouncing around underneath but
we think of it as this sort of
continuous fluid but we can have
features like a little Eddy in the water
which is made of molecules but which
molecules it's made of can change over
time but that Eddy has some kind of
character some kind of uh continued
persistence that is independent of the
details of the molecules which it's made
of it's just its overall structure has a
certain persistence and that's how we
think particles like electrons and so on
work in the universe in the actual space
that exists in the universe so in some
sense in our model the only thing in the
universe is space but space has features
that lead to the kinds of things we know
about like all these particles and so on
the particles and all these features of
space that we know and care about are a
tiny little piece of froth on top of the
main activity of the universe which is
just the continual rewriting of pieces
of space the sort of knitting together
pieces of space
so in our model the expansion of the
universe can actually be a growth in
this network you could start off with a
very small number of atoms of space
maybe just one and over time this
network is Rewritten and what was three
atoms of space will turn into something
with five atoms of space let's say that
it's all just you can kind of see it as
just rewriting of this network and so
in our model there actually can be more
space in the universe there can be
unlike in in general relativity in
standard sort of classical physics so to
speak you can uh I don't really know
what to call that our kind of physics
because in the sort of nomenclature of
physics there's classical physics which
was before the 1920s and um uh that did
not deal with quantum mechanics and so
on and then there's what is usually
called modern physics which is 1920s on
I suppose when I was learning about that
stuff in the 1960s it was still somewhat
modern but now we're another 50 years
later and I think it's kind of funny
that it's still called modern it reminds
me of these places where oh like when I
was uh in Oxford there are these
different colleges that are part of a
university in Oxford and one of those
colleges is called New college and you
might guess new college is actually the
second oldest college dating from
sometime in the 13 hundreds or something
it was called new College to distinguish
it from the original college but of
course now it's not new because it dates
from the 1300s so modern physics is
actually 100 years old
um and now we have a very different view
of how the foundations of physics work
that's come out of our physics project
and I guess it needs a new name so
people have suggestions for that name
they should make it because uh it's got
to get make it into the textbooks at
some point and you can't have a section
or a class on Modern physics it has to
be I don't post modern is not the right
word because that has too many other
other connotations and also that's kind
of not building for the future because
that's that's uh that's just a moment in
time type designation but in any case
in our view of physics the space
is consists of this kind of discrete
collection of atoms of space and there
can be more of it over time and in fact
the the expectation is that the
expansion of the universe is associated
with the actual making of more atoms of
space in the universe
now it gets a lot trickier than that
when you really start drilling down and
asking about what time is because you
know I'm talking about how the
university the the network is getting
Rewritten but different parts of the
network they will have the possibility
being Rewritten but you say are they
actually Rewritten well you can have
this kind of this notion of different
kind of reference frames where the
different parts of the universe are kind
of Rewritten and different orders and
all kinds of different things like this
so it gets a little bit more complicated
but the basic idea is you can think of
it as being okay at this moment you know
at the beginning of the universe there
were only you know two atoms of space or
something now there are 10 to the 400
atoms of space there are progressively
more atoms of space there's kind of more
Universe there now weird things can
happen in our models like pieces of the
universe can break off and it it that
can happen in uh well inside if you have
a black hole that's spinning too rapidly
you'll actually have a part of the
universe that breaks off as a separate
disc connected piece of the network so
it's uh you can both you can both make
more space and you can you can actually
decrease the number of atoms of space as
well through the actual rewrite of the
network you can also have pieces that
break off that are like uh you know
marooned pieces of the universe so to
speak so in our model of physics yes it
is possible to make more Universe you
can make more atoms of space
and uh it's some
but that's something that is as I would
say a little bit different in character
from the way one would normally think
about things in standard classical
general relativity classical sort of
theory of gravity you really don't talk
about more space you just talk about a
parameter that is the radius of the
universe basically that can increase
which is a little different than saying
there's more space there now you can
kind of I suppose when you start
thinking Even In classical classical
Quantum whatever physics
um you can uh uh maybe we should talk
about our physics as being rule physics
because it relates to pieces of the
rouliad which is this kind of entangled
limit of all possible computations so to
speak of which we get to sort of observe
just one slice but any case the the
thing that um
let's see I was I was going to say is uh
in
gosh that was that was a mistake for me
to have a digression there because uh I
think I lost my train of thought
um the uh
uh
yeah we're talking about kind of can
there be more uh yes yes so so in
traditional physics
the vacuum
the supposed emptiness of space
is not actually a vacuum it's not
actually empty according to Quantum
Mechanics there are all these always
these Quantum fluctuations and in fact
every particle electrons photons
whatever else virtual versions of that
particle together with antiparticle
continually come into existence and go
out of existence all the time and
there's this kind of zero point
fluctuations Quantum fluctuations that
exist even the vacuum so space in
quantum mechanics is is constantly
bubbling with these different particles
coming into existence going out of
existence we we don't get to make direct
observations of those things though
there are some experiments you can do
which show the existence of those kinds
of effects
now in our models our kind of knitting
together the structure of space by the
rewriting of this network
is kind of a very low level version of
those particle anti-particle vaccine
fluctuations vacuum fluctuations are a
kind of sign of that same sort of
activity through the knitting together
of the structure of space that uh one
has in the that we have this kind of
knitting together with such a space and
sort of high above that you can kind of
see the effects of that in these virtual
particles that come into existence go
out of existence it's always been kind
of a mystery that when these vertical
particles exist and they keep on
bubbling around they have a large
effective Mass they have such a large
effect of mass that if that mass existed
in the universe it would curl the
universe up into a little tiny ball and
there wouldn't be much universe that
wouldn't be able to expand in the way
the universe has expanded and and in our
models that doesn't happen because in a
sense all that energy all that mass
that's associated with in the end
virtual particles is the same activity
that is creating space in the first
place and so that means that it doesn't
have that same gravitational effect in
the usual Theory there's gravity on the
one hand which is being affected by all
of these virtual particles and the
virtual particles that they're sort of a
separate thing from Gravity it's like on
top of the gravity is sort of on top of
that whereas in our models these are all
integrated together and so there's no
longer that sort of paradox
so good question though
all right let's see
uh
Rock asks well actually I've got one
there's one here from Aaron
why does running my water pick interrupt
Bluetooth connections
so showing minor cultural knowledge of
water pick is this thing that uh squirts
high pressure water to clean out one's
teeth it actually is rather a rather a
nice device and um uh so
I assume it has an electric motor in it
and um uh the okay so Bluetooth
connections are the radio connections
between devices they're sort of very
commonly used whether it's between air
pods and a phone whether it's between or
any air almost anything tags pods
whatever
um it's it's a kind of a a short range
maybe well depending whether there's
obstructions in the way maybe 20 feet 50
feet kind of range of um of
communication of radio communication
and devices have this they're actually
different kinds of Bluetooth there's
Bluetooth and there's Bluetooth low
energy but they're they're similar for
these purposes and what's happening is
your
phone for example if you switch on
Bluetooth it's sending these radio
signals back and forth to whatever the
device you're communicating with and
they are oh gosh they must be radio
signals where the the wavelength is so I
would say
I think let's see
uh I have to work it out
[Music]
um
I think it's a few centimeters I think
that's right
um wavelength and it's Bluetooth is
not sending very much data
and it's doing it in a way that is
very much able to have errors that come
from the the the radio wave hitting some
metal pole and not and being distorted
and all this kind of thing those kinds
of Errors it is full of error correcting
codes that try to correct individual
pieces of the radio signal not having
arrived so Bluetooth is tends to be
within within its range it tends to be
fairly resilient to weird things
happening because it I I believe it is a
protocol that resends I believe it goes
both ways I believe it has a handshake
where the device that's receiving it
tells the device that's sending oh yes I
got that packet or no I didn't get that
packet that's the difference on the web
um between
um
uh TCP the usual protocol used for for
web browsers and UDP the protocol that's
used for streaming where it's just like
send the data out don't worry don't tell
the server whether you got it or not if
you need if you as the receiver found
you didn't get what you wanted you can
always request it but you don't
explicitly tell the tell the server
whether you got it so I think I'm I'm a
little surprised okay so what would what
would interrupt kind of that radio
signal well something else that's making
radio signals and there are things like
for example if you have a spark an
electrically generated spark a piece of
sort of micro lightning that's producing
radio energy at all radio frequencies
and or pretty much all radio frequencies
and so if you're if you have something
which is supposed to be receiving some
radio signal and there's this you know
there's this sort of micro lightning
strike then it's going to get a burst of
incorrect kind of from the micro
lightning strike rather than from the
original transmitter uh pieces of radio
energy and so it's going to get confused
it's not going to know what's going on
I'm surprised that a Bluetooth system
would get confused because I thought it
had good enough error correction
re-transmission that that wouldn't
happen but maybe if you have a device
that is continually having some little
short where it's got a little um I have
to believe that would run the batteries
down really quickly but maybe if it's
plugged into the wall it could have some
short that is producing enough radio
energy that it's able to kind of
interrupt the uh confuse the Bluetooth
communication
let's see question that was my attempt
at that at least without knowing more
all right Rock asks
says in third grade I had an argument
with a teacher she said before humans
had language they thought just like us I
argue that couldn't be true instead
language gave a way to complex thoughts
was I right
well interesting question I mean there's
been a long tradition in philosophy kind
of linguistic tradition of philosophy
that kind of a lot of that kind of
conflates
Thoughts with language so to speak
the question is
well first of all what is language what
and how does it relate to thoughts
you know in our brains we've got 100
billion-ish neurons they're firing all
the time you know a thousand times a
second in many cases lots of electrical
signals going on in our brains lots of
stuff happening in our brains
but somehow we communicate things that
are happening in our brains to other
humans and how do we do that well you
know if you could take some kind of
version if you could get all the
electrical signals from my brain and you
could kind of play that into your brain
it probably wouldn't be terribly useful
because your brain is set up in a
different way than my brain everybody's
brain is set up in a different way the
details of where the neurons are exactly
which neuron fires when this is going on
that's all different so you can't really
just take kind of an engram of one brain
and sort of plug it into another brain
instead you have to have some way of
taking the thoughts in one brain and
packaging them up in some robust way so
that they can be communicated to another
brain and I think that's sort of in the
end that's kind of what language is
doing for us it's taking this incoherent
collection of kind of nerve firings in
my brain and allowing me to form a word
like brain or something and that word
represents a concept which is some whole
giant collection of neuron firings in my
brain that word is then something that I
can robustly communicate to another
brain that other brain can unpack the
word and turn it into that whole
collection of nerve firings that they
have themselves
and so in a sense that's sort of what
language is doing is encapsulating it's
it's kind of it's it's making a sort of
package from thoughts going on in my
brain packaging it up so that it is uh
sort of compatible with transmission to
another brain
so this question of whether there is
sort of stuff going on in my brain even
without having formed it into that
packaging is an interesting question
their undoubtedly is I mean even in the
lowest sort of animals which have brains
we can see there's brain activity
there's thoughts going on in some sense
now maybe you don't want to call them
thoughts because a thought not
expressible a thought that's mere nerve
firings is it a thought so for example
let's say there are parts of my brain
that you know there's a part of my brain
that's important for keeping my heart
beating there's a part of my brain
that's important for regulating
temperature the part of my brain that
has to do with dealing with certain sort
of reflexes and so on some of that is
carried out not not in the brain but to
just in in nerve trunks in the spinal
cord and things like that but the um
so there's parts of my brain where there
are nerve firings and there's things
happening you know heartbeats are going
on things like this are those nerve
firings
things in my brain that we should call
thoughts perhaps not perhaps the part of
our brains that keeps our heart beating
is it's it's brain activity but it's not
thought
and that's you know in in um there's
sort of a a concept and and for sort of
lower animals and things there are
things that happen that keep their
hearts beating and things like that
which you might not say are thoughts
so you know this question of whether
whether it raises to the level of being
a thought you might argue that it's not
a convincing thought until you can
package it up in this kind of linguistic
lump that can be communicated to another
human
I think the uh
the question of whether
whether our brains whether we can sort
of uh in in our brains to what extent
are we doing things that represent sort
of a a whole Tower of kind of thinking
and to what extent are we just like uh
you know
we see the banana we pick the banana
type thing I mean to what extent are we
just doing that sort of short-term Loop
of the kind of like the like the
reflexes that we have you know if you if
you uh you know hit your leg just below
your knee or your your lower leg will
kick out that's a that's a reflex
um that uh
um is something that is just associated
with low level operation of the nervous
system and that uh you could sort of
generalize that a bit that you know the
the animal does this or that just based
on its low level reflexes and you could
say well that's not real thinking to get
real thinking you need to be able to go
sit there and Ponder and go from one
thought to another to another and to
sort of Stack the thoughts up to get to
something which is kind of a more a more
derived kind of thing and that's related
to things like planning can you decide
you know if you see the banana and you
can can reach out and pick it that's one
thing but if you get this stick and you
hit piece of the tree and then you do
this and then you do that and you're
kind of using tools you're doing this
whole plan that involves kind of a stack
of thoughts to get to the thing you want
to get to then that's a more convincing
kind of thinking process so now the
question is what does it take to have a
stack of thoughts what does it take to
be able to stack one sort of concept or
one thing on top of another maybe it
takes within one's own brain some kind
of way in which one has a kind of mind's
language that is a packaging within
one's own brain of the same kind that we
have of packaging from one brain to
another maybe in order to build those
towers of thoughts we have to be able to
kind of encapsulate all those neuron
firings into oh yeah that's a concept
it's a robust thing we can take that we
can now sort of take a modular version
of that and then build the next thing on
top of it maybe we need to have that
kind of thing in order to have serious
internal sort of sustained thinking I
don't think anybody knows in fact you
know I was just doing some experiments
myself on artificial neural networks and
it's a little bit harder to see in the
case of uh large language models where
they're producing language
um if you say well what happens if you
break a piece of the network if you just
say I'll zero out that part of the
network what happens well it'll start
getting saying words wrong and it'll
start making mistakes to various kinds
and eventually it'll just it'll start
you know speaking total nonsense and
then it'll maybe just fall silent you
can do the same thing with image
generation and there you can kind of
knock out pieces of the artificial brain
that's generating the image and you
start seeing these weird different
images being produced it's kind of
looking at something where you start off
from this this brain that's aligned and
sort of works well maybe not quite the
same way human brains work but it's
aligned with kind of human thinking in
the sense that it knows kind of the
types of images that we are used to
seeing and then you say well let's
perturb that let's make an alien mind
that's a bit different from that what
does it see in its Mind's Eye so to
speak when it's sort of synthesizing
these images you could do the same thing
what does it what does it see in its in
its sort of Minds language
um if it's synthesizing language and you
can see it kind of diverge from human
language
but so so I think that's that's kind of
a way of perhaps thinking about this
question of is there is there thought
without language it's not transmittable
brain to brain without language or
something like language it's
um uh it might not be buildable up in
many steps even within one brain without
that but we don't know that yet
um I think that's a it's an interesting
question I mean in fact with large
language models like chat gbt and so on
one of the weird things is that the the
inner thoughts when it generates one new
word is just sort of Rippling through
the neural net with all kinds of
complicated stuff with all kinds of
numbers being added and multiplied and
all this kind of thing and then it
produces a word
and then when it's going to produce the
next word it has a sort of outer loop
where it's looking at all the words it's
made so far and then deciding how to
produce the next word and and that kind
of outer loop is I think the um
uh that that's kind of analogous to it
had to have language to have that outer
loop it had to be looking at these words
It produced it's not good enough for it
to be looking at at least in the way
that we architect neural Nets right now
it's not good enough for it to be taking
the inner thoughts so to speak it needs
to have this outer loop where it could
definitively produced a piece of
language which could it can then look at
and then build for the next thing so I
think that that's kind of at least in
the current architecture of something
like that that kind of argues for the
idea that you sort of need language to
build a tower of thoughts
um it's kind of a Chain of Thought
reasoning is what people are calling it
in the case of of large language models
and um uh you know it's possible that
the way brains are architected that's
something you fundamentally need and
that's kind of an argument why you're uh
um uh
well that you might have been right that
um you know language is what made
possible complex Thoughts by being able
to sort of build these towers and brains
where that wouldn't have been possible
if you've been if you hadn't had sort of
modularized these things under Concepts
a few thoughts there
let's see
robot asks why do many medications have
side effects
interesting well so
you know you make up some chemical some
drug
you create it
people figure out oh we want this
molecule that has a certain shape that's
going to fit into this other molecule
that's going to cause us to uh I don't
know have you know be better with
respect to some disease or whatever else
um so
your
your kind of you have a particular
Target in mind you have a particular
thing we say I want this drug this
medication to do this particular thing
okay great well the problem is that
there are many different ways in which
the that molecule for example can do
things other than the thing you intended
it to do so for example a very simple
case would be
there's a molecule and it's supposed to
fit into a hole another molecule to gum
up that hole to prevent something else
happening from that hole in that
molecule and a lot of the way we operate
to the level of molecular biology has to
do with what molecule fits into what
molecule in what way this molecule fits
in there so it can react so it's you
know held in place so it can react with
another molecule Etc et cetera et cetera
it's a very that's very common that's a
lot of how we work inside so to speak at
the molecular level okay so now you
build this molecule and people try and
figure it out with computers with with
uh with all kinds of things they'll test
all kinds of different sources of
molecules and things they'll say what's
a molecule that correctly gums up that
hole great okay they find such a
molecule and then they say okay that's
good now the question is it has that
effect but is there anywhere else in the
body where it might sort of gum up a
different hole it wasn't the one you
intended to gum up or might attach to
something different that wasn't the one
you intended
well that's the first question
second thing is we'll we all have the
molecules the proteins that we're made
of they're all a little bit different
between different ones of us because our
DNA our original genetic material is
slightly different and that means there
will be small differences one you know
tiny region uh one amino acid and a
protein that proteins are chains of
amino acids they might be a chain of a
thousand or a million amino acids no
maybe um yeah that's actually the
biggest ones are that size but you know
hundreds to thousands to tens of
thousands of amino acids and you know
the different people will have
individual pieces of those chains that
are different
and so the the issue is if you have made
this wonderful molecule this wonderful
drug that you say oh yeah it fits right
in this hole for a protein where I
tested that protein you say well what
about somebody else's version of that
protein maybe that will have an extra
little lat ledge on it and that extra
ledge will prevent the molecule from
sticking in or maybe they'll see some
completely different Protein that's
somewhere completely different in the
body where that drug molecule will
somehow be able to attach to that
completely different protein so that's a
a common reason why there are sort of
side effects is that the thing that you
thought was going to only you know sort
of attach to the molecule is only going
to attach to one thing actually attaches
to other things instead and there are
other reasons for for side effects I
mean there are there are sometimes side
effects are not very well understood and
um it's uh
uh they're uh
um the uh uh I mean there are there are
a lot of
um
side effects some some of them happen
quickly some of them happen slowly some
of them gradually build up if you take
too much of this drug over a long period
of time some system in your body will go
out of balance because it was sort of
expecting one thing but it was
continually getting another thing there
are other things that can happen in the
more physical characters pieces of in
the body things like the kidneys where
you're filtering the blood and so on the
the uh the little very fine sort of uh
fine mesh of the filters can be damaged
by molecules of different kinds and so
on same things can happen in in the
lungs if you're inhaling stuff and so on
there are all kinds of detailed sort of
physical effects that can happen and one
thing that happens is because well not
only are the our detailed molecules
different there are also differences in
the sort of physical setup of you know
the the the the details of the the the
kind of the little
um little kind of branches and lungs or
something might be different they might
be different in one person from another
because of a difference in the
environment that they're in they might
have all kinds of reasons why there's
differences and so that means that the
the thing that was tested on a thousand
people and it says okay great this works
perfectly for a thousand people and they
never had any bad effect the the
thousand and first person might have a
different enough set of molecules or
different enough physical setup about
some part of their body that the
molecule has a has a different effect on
them than it does to on all the people
who are tested and so then you would
have what would normally be called a
side effect of some kind
um that was something that wasn't
expected I I think it's one of these
things that it's really inevitable that
there will be unexpected effects it's
kind of a a consequence of sort of
pretty deep kind of ideas about sort of
the way that the way that things work
and sort of mutation and so on that
there will always be these sort of
unexpected effects and it gets more
complicated when the thing that you're
using is not just a a single molecule a
drug that's just okay we've got this
this molecule that's a drug but let's
say you have this drug that's really
clever and it's sort of an algorithmic
drug where it can compute things and
adapt itself even at a molecular level
then you ask well look could there be a
side effect and then you're really
asking something that is very much like
you're debugging a program there's this
molecule that's sort of flapping around
like a you know executing a program and
you're saying in its interaction with
this whole environment that is us could
we end up with some place where we
essentially uh see a bug in this program
that will be found for this one in a
billion people type type situation so
that's a a slight idea of how that works
let's see
there's a question here why do we yawn
our yawns truly contagious
um a couple of things to say about that
I think the reason one yawns is that the
uh in
um uh the you know we're we're trying to
get into our lungs oxygen which is about
20 or one-fifth of of air is oxygen
that's the part that matters to us in
terms of of running our bodies and we're
trying to get oxygen into our lungs by
breathing in air and uh we're trying to
um uh get sort of enough oxygen down to
all those layers of branching they're
like 23 layers of branching in the lungs
from from really big sort of the big
sort of windpipe in our throats down to
little tiny tiny branches that
eventually get small enough that the
oxygen in the air in our lungs is so
close to our blood that that is within
uh two millionths of a meter two microns
of of um uh that um it can the the
oxygen molecules can diffuse through
these membranes into our blood and can
be picked up by hemoglobin and our red
blood cells and so on and can be
transported around our body to provide
the sort of the raw material the oxygen
is part of the raw material for
metabolism for the chemical reactions
that happen in our body so we need a
certain amount of oxygen and I think the
usual claim for why we yawn is that if
the carbon dioxide level which is you
know we inhale oxygen we exhale carbon
dioxide if we it's not all carbon
dioxide that we exhale but there's more
carbon dioxide and while we exhale and
what we inhale but what we inhale is uh
actually I had a little sensor I think
even though I'm I can say that it's it's
some uh let's see 500 parts per million
I think I think it's in parts per
million in uh
um right now right here so to speak but
you know in general it's like 400 500
depends is where you are if you're
inside and there's lots of people you're
in a room and you know it's full of
people breathing out and there's no
fresh air coming in you'll if you take a
carbon dioxide meter you'll see it
climbing up it'll get to a thousand
parts per million I think
um and and go beyond when you're in a
stuffy room so to speak
um people are breathing out come a
certain amount of carbon dioxide
breathing in oxygen I think the claim is
that one yawns because somehow one's
brain is sensing sort of there's too
much carbon dioxide we need to gulp in
more more oxygen quite why that relates
to being tired I'm not quite sure I'm
not sure as I tell you that explanation
which is one that I've heard over
decades ago
um I'm I'm not I'm not quite as
convinced by it as as I might be so but
that's I think the traditional
explanation now are yawns contagious you
know everything is somehow contagious
there are in our brains sometimes people
call them mirror neurons there's
definite sort of circuitry in our brain
that says if you see somebody doing
something you imitate what they're doing
that's probably a very important piece
of how we learn as as babies so to speak
how we learn how anything works if we
didn't have that sort of built-in
circuit that like do what's what you
know do what you're seeing so to speak
that it will be very hard for us to
learn things we kind of learn by
imitation in the first level so so it's
very common if you're you know if you're
talking to someone you notice it all the
time you know somebody will adjust their
glasses and then the person they're
talking to will adjust their glasses if
they have glasses or somebody will will
do something and the person they're
talking to will kind of reflect that and
what they do and that seems to be a
thing that is kind of a a Vestige
perhaps of something which is important
for very early life for humans of
learning things maybe it's something
that's part of the way that sort of
social interaction Works in even adult
humans I'm not sure maybe it's part of
kind of how humans realize that they're
kind of in sync with each other oh that
person just did something like what I
did so they're paying attention to me so
to speak uh maybe maybe maybe the lack
of that in some situations with uh with
virtual in some virtual situations might
be why how one I think that might be a
little bit how one knows that somebody
sort of isn't paying attention is that
they're not reacting and sometimes that
reaction is an imitation of what they're
seeing so to speak so I kind of suspect
that the contagion of yawns is a
contagion of everything it's probably a
contagion of of you know uh scratching
one's ear and it's a contagion of other
things too I don't think it's any more
and my guess is that it's it's
contagious because of this generic sort
of imitation characteristic rather than
something else
let's see oh boy lots of good questions
here there's a question from Jamie why
do cats meow dogs bark birds chirp
well
you know I I gather that um the cat's
meow is an evolved trait if you look at
wild cats they have a different sound
the the the expectation is that
domesticated cats are the cats are not I
don't know they're not as domesticated
as some other animals but but the
somewhat domesticated cats that we have
and the breeds of cats people are
produced and so on
that part of their sound has been
adapted to be uh sort of happy to be
around humans just like I think cats by
Nature sort of tend to run away from
everything and the ones that are the
domesticated version like hanging out
with people which probably isn't their
natural way and so that that um but in
terms of of these different sounds you
know one thing to realize is
part of the sound of an animal has to do
with how big it is just like with humans
you know young kids will have much
higher pitched voices because when the
air is being uh sort of vibrated in
their in their vocal cords and that in
their throat the the the the size of the
region is much smaller and so that leads
to much higher pitch sound just like if
you have a string you know with a
stringed instrument or something the
little tiny piece of string will make a
much higher pitch than the big long
piece of string that vibrates more
slowly and makes a lower pitch so the
the the kind of the the the smaller the
animal the smaller the throat of the
animal so to speak where the sound is
being made the higher pitch the the
animal will tend to have and when you
get you know what might be a purr in a
cat in a domestic cat will turn into a a
Roar and a lion just because even though
the lion has sort of the same circuitry
potentially as a cat making a purr the
purr turns into this much lower lower
frequency rumbling in the bigger lion so
to speak
now I think that different animals have
different characteristics in their in
their vocal tracts and their throats and
the where where the air goes into their
lungs like we humans have vocal cords
which have very detailed uh control by
by our nerves that allow us to make the
sounds that correspond to to speaking
and you know that's that's part of the
story the other part of the story is how
we form our mouths to make different
kinds of sounds like we might make a you
know an S hissing sound that hissing is
turbulent air
um in our mouths being sort of forced
through a small small Gap and then in
sort of phonetics there are all these
different names you know glottal stops
that's a that's a thing when you close
down your throat and then labials that's
I think from the front a lay allele
labial it has to do with rolling your
tongue out into the front of your mouth
and so on and though those are your
generating sort of a a uh uh you're
generating the um the sound in your
vocal cords and then it's being sort of
adapted by the by this uh uh by what's
happening in your mouth
now birds for example have a different
setup they have a thing called the
syrinx
um and birds are able to make for
example we can just make a single you
know when you sing you typically make a
single note that's that's what you know
you're you're going you have a single
it's not it's not all precisely
concentrated at one frequency it's not a
pure tone but you're making you know you
sing one note then another note another
note
birds can effectively sing two notes at
a time it's much like you know on on an
old-fashioned uh uh Touchstone phone you
always have two frequencies one for the
sort of horizontal position of the key
one for the vertical position that's
kind of like what birds chirp they chirp
sort of two frequencies at a time
different from what we humans what we
humans do so they're these different
sort of uh different structures in the
in the vocal tract in the throat of
these different animals that lead to
different uh different kinds of sounds
and uh I think um
in terms of of whether there is a sort
of evolutionary value you know like I
mentioned with the cats as they become
domesticated their their their meows and
things have apparently become adapted to
being around humans
um and uh so one might ask what was the
adaptation that led to different kinds
of sounds for different kinds of animals
you know for Birds
um I think the there are a certain you
know a common thing with certain kinds
of animals is you know it's kind of like
the the uuid of the animal it's like I'm
gonna chop just this way and so you know
it's me so to speak or this you know
with birds there tend to be this kind of
seasonal Fashions very much like with
humans where there'll be a song and the
song will start become popular it'll go
to the top of the bird charts all the
birds will be chopping that song for a
season and then the next uh the next
song will come around next season it's
kind of shocking how similar to the sort
of the human can condition that really
is I do remember when I was a kid in
England the um uh the phones that they
were always in those days it was the
government uh you know the the post
office as it was as it was sort of
operated all the phones and so you've
got sort of the government phones and
there were a limited number of kinds of
phones same in the US until until the
Bell System uh was um uh was was broken
up in the 80s
um
that you know there were a limited
number of kinds of phones but anyway one
of the things that there was this sort
of there had been phones which just rang
a bell so to speak when they you know
when the phone was ringing it was you
know it was just something hitting a a a
sort of bell type thing to make the make
the sound to tell you there was a phone
call but then in a piece of modernity
that turned into an electronic uh kind
of synthesizer and it made more of a you
know I can't imitate it type sound
um and the funny thing was that over a
summer
the birds heard those sounds all over
England and birds started making those
sounds and it was super confusing
because you would hear that sound and
it's like is that a bird is that a phone
you couldn't tell anyway just an amusing
thing that happened that was sort of an
adaptation of the birds to their
environment the phone environment so to
speak uh that one was able to see over
that short of time scale
uh
M asks why can't AI help us analyze
animal sounds a lot of people thinking
about that right now
um there is a certain extent to which it
can I mean you know we've even done
experiments from from looking at some
I've always been curious about this
question about sort of communicating
with alien minds and you know the
animals on the Earth are a great example
of kind of Minds different from our
human minds and so you know you look at
whale songs and things like this and you
say can you recognize the phonemes the
the lumps of sound the repeated lumps of
sound yeah you can recognize those kinds
of things can you recognize sort of
phrases can you recognize repeated
phrases you recognize things at that
level of structure the answer is yes and
you can pick those things out pretty
easily with with AI
the next question is can you associate
what when a whale goes whatever whatever
a whale does when it or a bird chirps in
a particular way but let's take a whale
because they seem to be probably
communicating in a way that's more
obviously like like language
um you know what does it mean when it
makes this this particular kind of whale
song sound well for that we have to
associate kind of we have to know just
like if you're trying to learn some
language somebody has to show you an
apple and tell you that that is a
particular word in the language you're
trying to learn so similarly in the case
of the whales it's like okay we hear a
whale sound what does that whale what
does the whale mean by that whale sound
well potentially we get to correlate the
behavior of the whale with the sound
they make and perhaps we can figure out
what that sound means nobody's managed
to do that yet but there's a hope that
even in The Fairly near term there's
lots of data being taken that that may
be something that becomes clear now it's
a tricky business because you know the
whale doesn't do things that are like
what we sort of terrestrial humans with
pans and all that kind of thing tend to
do so for the whale it may be saying you
know don't you know there's this ocean
current that goes this way and it has a
weird Corkscrew you know effect and Etc
et cetera et cetera and that in whale is
some you know complicated sequence of
whale sounds and we just see the whale
sounds we see the whale it's swimming
around Etc et cetera Etc we never know
to go check the velocity field of this
thing and see whether it has some
variants across the you know the left
flipper and the right flipper of the
whale and things like that we don't know
what it you know we hear that sound but
we don't know what it's to be correlated
with the same kind of thing when people
have measured in for example cats people
have measured the in the neurons in the
visual cortex of the cat they've
measured kind of the effect of different
visual stimuli and some visual stimuli
like you can tell oh yes that neuron
fires when the cat sees a black blob
that neuron fires when it sees a black
blob with white surrounding it that one
fires when it sees a vertical stripe
that one when it's horizontal stripe and
so on and then there are neurons that
you see firing when it's when the cat is
just looking at some visual scene but
you don't know why they're firing you
don't know what feature of the visual
scene made those neurons fire and I
think it's the same kind of thing with
trying to correlate kind of the sounds
the vocalizations of animals with their
sort of environment is like well what
part of their environment should we be
paying attention to and and potentially
you know if we have sensors that sort of
replicate the sensors on the whale and
we feed All Those sensors to the AI it
might have a chance of picking up
whatever it was that the whale sensed
there but you know if the whales are
debating philosophy across the Pacific
Ocean or something because their sounds
carry a long way in the deep ocean if
they're debating philosophy whale
philosophy good luck to us in decoding
what an Earth is going on or if they are
you know telling you know if they're
like the homeric bards or something
telling the the uh the Epic story maybe
they're telling the uh their side of the
Epic story of you know Ahab and Moby
Dick or something like this
um and you know they've been telling it
for the last whales live a long time
they've been telling it for the last you
know couple of centuries or something
back and forth and we'd have no idea how
to correlate that with sort of the uh uh
the oh yes this whale sense this
particular thing that we can detect you
know the whales saw a giant squid and
it's telling all its other whale friends
did you see that giant squid I've never
seen one as big as that well you have a
hope if you have a sensor that's
watching what the whale's eyes see and
they can you can see that it saw a giant
squid you have a hope of being able to
correlate that but that's a um that's a
complicated thing
let's see
uh
uh let's see
um
here's one that may be as simple that's
always dangerous when I say that from
Tenacious do photons run through
antimatter does that make them matter
okay so what antimatter always is is you
have something like an electron it has a
certain Mass it has a certain charge
the anti-electron has the same mass as
the electron but it has the opposite
charge to the electron and so when an
electron and a positron which is an
anti-electron meet they can that you
need to the result is there's a plus
charge and a minus charge and whatever
they turn into has to have zero charge
and or at least the the total charge has
to be zero they typically will turn into
a bunch of photons
photons have the feature that they are
their own antiparticle photons don't
have any charge and so an anti-foton is
just a photon so when a photon
encounters antimatter it's just it's
like okay this is an electron this is a
positron uh okay I do what I do when I
encounter an electron like thing it's no
different between encountering an
electron and encountering a positron and
so for example well if you were to uh
you know have a beam of electrons and a
beam of photons and they interact and
you get various kinds of scattering
between the uh the photon beam and the
Electron Beam it'll scatter in one way
you do the same thing with positrons
exactly the same effects will be exactly
the same in fact so far as we know those
two things that there could be a
difference the because of the details of
how Quantum field Theory works if you're
running sort of forwards in time and
you're looking at that scattering
process it could be the case that for an
electron an appositron there was a
slight difference in what you would get
it seems that that isn't true
technically it means that charge
conjugation uh is the the
electromagnetic uh force is invariant
under charge conjugation Symmetry and
that that's sort of a fancy way of
saying it doesn't care whether it's um
the the photon just doesn't care whether
it's interacting with an electron or a
positron it does it in exactly the same
way so that that's why uh photons don't
that their their own anti-particle they
don't care
um
let's see
Des asks is chemistry really just
physics
it's an interesting question back in the
day this chap called Ernest Rutherford
the guy who discovered the atomic
nucleus
um the uh uh was um a rather disparaging
he thought of himself as a physicist and
rather disparagingly said really there
are two branches of science he was
thinking physics and chemistry he says
there's physics and there's stamp
collecting by that he meant that in
physics there are systematic laws and we
can learn a small number of systematic
laws in chemistry it's like they're all
these different things and all these
different molecules and it's like
collecting stamps from around the world
it's kind of like there's no regularity
there's no principles in it it's just
all it happens to be this it happens to
be that and so on
well so interesting claim and quote
well let's talk about what
chemistry is about chemistry is about
the interactions between atoms and
molecules and so on and those atoms and
molecules are described by the quantum
mechanics of physics and so on in
principle you can compute what happens
given given the laws of physics you can
in principle work out the structure of a
water molecule you can in principle work
out what will happen when this molecule
not crashes into this molecule Etc
and practice it's really hard to work
those things out even after all these
years with all the computational tools
we have we can't work out that much
about the structure of for example
anything but fairly small molecules and
when it comes to how molecules collide
with each other and react there's
surprisingly little that we can actually
work out in practice with the computers
we have today and with all the
techniques we have nowadays there's a
lot of machine learning techniques that
are useful for being able to sort of
remember different sort of fragments of
how things work and fit them together we
we have a a hard time sort of actually
working that out from the physics in
principle we could work out we think we
can work out how all these things in
chemistry work but not in practice
and there's this phenomenon I call
computational irreducibility this idea
that once you know the rules for a
computational system it may take you
actually just explicitly following those
rules step by step by step to work out
how that system will behave there may be
sort of no fast way to jump ahead and
see what happens and I think that's what
chemistry basically is it's physics and
computational irreducibility so there's
physics underneath that says yes these
are the detailed Rules by which the
individual electrons and individual
atoms work but by the time we try and
aggregate that up into so what's the
property of this big molecule with a
thousand atoms in it that's something
that's a computationally irreducible
thing to work out it takes sort of an
irreducible amount of computational
effort to figure that out and so that
means in some sense that while chemistry
is in principle derivable from physics
in practice there's this irreducible
computational barrier in in
describing chemistry from physics so in
that sense chemistry really is in some
sense as separated from physics well in
some sense when we think about our own
minds and how we work and whether we
have free will and and how we decide to
do this thing or that thing those things
are also ultimately determined by
physics but that's not how we think
about them we we feel we have free will
we feel we have something that is sort
of irreducibly distant from the
underlying physics by which we operate
and I think it's sort of the same thing
in chemistry a little bit less distance
than perhaps with human minds but
there's still there's a distance and
it's sort of this irreducible
computational distance so there is
something sort of fundamentally
different about the chemistry that we
look at that is as Rutherford called it
this sort of stamp collections of all
these different things that happen in
chemistry versus what happens in physics
now the question is are there principles
in chemistry as there are principles in
physics well the problem is that since
chemistry is built on top of this
computational irreducibility say that
kind of tells you right there that there
will be less principles there will be
there'll be some principles but there'll
be things that are hard to work out from
principles there are things where you
just have to have measured it and see
what happens because in a sense to say
there's a principle is to say you can
jump ahead of this computational
irreducibility and that's something
which there's always pieces of
reducibility there's always places where
you can jump ahead but there can be a
big sort of ocean of irreducibility and
I think that's kind of what you see in
the kind of stamp collecting aspects of
chemistry now I think that there are
things about chemistry that there are
principles of chemistry that perhaps are
well chemistry
there's there's so much in chemistry
that is not really that well understood
now it's interesting how Fields work you
know chemistry had a really golden age
in the late 1800s people were
discovering all these different kinds of
reactions and figuring out all these
different ways to make things and then
again when plastic and things got
invented 1920s 1930s and so on so
another kind of big sort of burst of
chemistry physics had this big burst of
activity in the 1920s particularly
um and uh these were sort of different
bursts of activity I think uh you know
chemistry
is probably due for another another
burst of activity and it might even
relate to well one of the questions is
when we describe sort of what's
happening in chemistry by what means do
we describe it the very the typical way
you describe chemistry is although these
chemical reactions they're these
molecules they're sort of randomly
bouncing around in a gas and a liquid
for example that sort of randomly
bouncing around every so often two
molecules will collide if the molecules
are in the right orientation and so on
they'll stick into each other and
there'll be a chemical reaction and
they'll turn it out of the molecules and
you know I think that there are sort of
questions about well if the the
traditional view of chemistry is just
there's a there's a rate of reaction
that's just all these molecules are
randomly bouncing around my guess is
that particularly when it comes to
molecular biology to sort of chemistry
of life that there are other effects
that are quite important that have to do
with well these two molecules collided
those same two molecules might meet each
other again you know a millionth of a
second later or something but that's not
something accounted for In traditional
views of chemistry this kind of causal
graph of which molecules interact with
each molecule is something that isn't
really thought about it's all kind of
randomized and so you know there are
things like that that that's one kind of
area there are things that there are a
lot of reasons why I think there's a
there's a chance that some some sort of
exciting principle-based things might
happen in chemistry in the not too
distant future and certainly the the
sort of merger of thinking about
molecules as things that can compute and
so on is a whole nother direction to
chemistry
let's see maybe a few more
um
let's see
people asking does brain size have any
correlation to IQ
um
I think the answer is no
um I think that you know it well there's
several points
first
the notion of IQ is a very funky notion
it's a notion was invented about 100
years ago as kind of a a you know we can
measure the height of a person we can
measure the weight of a person
surely we can measure something about
the mental functioning of a person and
surely we can get one number that
characterizes that just like we can get
one number which is the height of the
person well really if we really wanted
to be Persnickety about it we wouldn't
have just one number that's the side of
the person because it depends on you
know are you measuring it you know is it
the really tippy top of their head or is
it you know is it at this angle is it at
that angle but we kind of know there's
one number that characterizes the height
of a person
um the question is is there sort of one
number that characterizes the the uh
something about the thinking processes
of a person
the answer is quite plainly no which is
hardly a surprise and it's like saying
you know I have a computer or a program
on a computer can I characterize is this
program sort of can I give one number
that characterizes oh this computer is
is sort of is This effective and that
computer is that effective I can't
really do that there are things like the
clock speed of the computer the amount
of memory the computer has those are
things you can measure but the the sort
of ability of the computer is something
where there isn't just one number that
measures it and and all nor is there
with humans and you know it tends to be
kind of a put up job because you know
you can make an IQ test so-called IQ
test and you know the IQ test has a
particular form you know you'll say
what's the odd
shape out in this picture Etc et cetera
et cetera and uh if people have never
seen those before there's a certain oei
can figure this out and people who are
have seen things like that before will
be able to do it faster than people who
haven't the people who who really
practice on those kinds of problems will
be able to do it much better and so on
there's a uh there's but it's also the
case that there tends to be this kind of
baggage associated with oh I can do this
odd thing out in this
you know picture of blocks and so on I
can do that really well so I'm really
quotes generally smart and I'm going to
be able to solve these big problems in
uh when it comes to uh I don't know
working out the strategy for some
company or something like that doesn't I
don't think it works that way I think
that our brains like computers and so on
are very they have lots of different
abilities which are determined uh
probably to some extent by the hardware
of the brain and to a large extent by
kind of what the brain learned and also
how the brain is exercised so to speak
what what it learned and what it learned
to learn and all those kinds of things
when it comes to the raw Hardware of the
brain that they're certainly every brain
is different brains are are much more
different than fingerprints the kind of
foldings of brains are even uh you know
each different person has a different
characteristic folding of brain of their
brain and so on what effect that has I
don't think anyone he knows there are
certainly examples where people had
various kinds of diseases where their
brain was kind of crushed into a pretty
small volume but they didn't that didn't
really affect their their uh their sort
of ability to to think with their brain
so to speak there are cases I mean it's
some pure brain mass is unlikely I think
to be I don't know to be it'll it'll be
I'm sure there will be an interesting
question what behavioral characteristics
of a human can you identify that would
be correlated with straight brain mass I
don't know I don't think I don't think
that's a known thing I think that um I
also don't even know I mean there's sort
of a question of of is a bigger brain
better not obviously true you know it
takes longer for signals to go across a
bigger brain maybe if you want to have
coherent thoughts it's better not to
have a bigger brain because you know in
a bigger brain there might be more
different things going on that are
incoherent with each other and you
wouldn't be able to sort of form as
clear a chain of thoughts so you know I
think it could go in many different
directions and I I I'm I'm not aware of
of um of that term
um
of that feature I think um uh
yeah Zayden is commenting the hardware
the brain is an ongoing process
especially in childhood nurture
environment Society Etc can cause
changes in brain Hardware
yeah I don't I don't know I mean
certainly in things like the
neurotransmitters the actual sort of
chemicals that are are produced in the
brain absolutely there are things like
you know if you have a uh lots of stress
for a long time it can affect those
kinds of things or all sorts of uh
things like that I'm not sure that it's
really known what effect
uh maybe it's known from from animals
like mice and so on what effect uh on
the actual individual neurons in a brain
different kinds of environmental
features have I think um uh there are
certainly things known about well diet
for example I mean famously uh the uh oh
and the Potato Famine of 150 years ago
or something there was some that led to
vitamin A deficiency I guess
which led to retinal damage which led to
which I think is is partly heritable
um there's a weird case where where what
happens to one generation during the
course of their life can affect the Next
Generation but I think there are things
like that where I mean the the retina in
the eye can certainly be affected by
those things I don't know what yes there
must be well I know there are all sorts
of terrible things that happen when uh
uh you know
when when fetuses are exposed to drugs
of various kinds there are all sorts of
bad things that can happen that affect
brain chemistry I don't know whether
they affect brain structure I know they
affect brain chemistry and the
neurotransmitters and so on which are
which are kind of um uh sort of small
smaller molecules that well the
molecules that kind of can diffuse
around in the brain rather than the
actual sort of structure of neurons with
dendrites and things like that and I
don't think it's it is certainly known
it was for a long time believed that for
humans you're born with a certain brain
and all that ever happens is neurons die
over the course of your life and you
never get new neurons eventually it was
discovered that that's not true actually
and there are new neurons that can be
produced even in the adult brain and uh
some of us who who pride ourselves on
using our brains quite a bit have the at
least idea that if you use your brain a
lot maybe you'll grow new neurons just
like you know if you use your muscles a
lot you'll grow bigger muscles and
you'll get some more more pieces of of
muscle filament in there I I don't know
if this is true I don't think anybody
knows whether that's true at this point
um but it's uh it's kind of a fun thing
to imagine at least
um
yeah spare parts are the bigger brains
actually have more functional neurons
rather they're just more spread out I do
not know I don't think it's known it's
only very recently that people have good
estimates of the number of of neurons in
a human brain and the estimate I keep on
persistently seeing is 86 billion and I
I would be very very surprised if that
number is is that constant I would I
would guess that that number will vary
by I don't know 10 or something in a
brain just like you know human Heights
and things vary by well what is it it
must be um uh more than 10 percent 20 25
so I think it's um my guess is that that
won't be a constant number but it's only
been rather recently surprisingly
recently that one's been able to sort of
essentially dissolve a brain and keep
the neurons intact and count the neurons
um and in the past would have been more
likely to take micro microscopic slices
of brains and you try and count the
neurons there but that's really hard to
do because neurons are long spindly
things and it's hard to know if this
microscope slice here oh and by the way
neurons also are um uh they tend to be
sort of semi-transparent one of the
weird tricks is this thing called Golgi
staining where you put a chemical into
something like brain tissue and uh one
in a thousand neurons turn purple nobody
knows which which characteristic the
ones that turn purple have that
distinguishes the others but it's very
useful because that means you can kind
of see sort of there's this there's a
sort of background of semi-transparent
stuff and then you see this one purple
neuron sort of snaking through and you
can kind of see the shape of it but it's
been really hard to count neurons that
way I must say I've been asking people
for for like decades why can't you just
dissolve the thing and just have the
neurons kind of come apart and count
them and people have always told me oh
you can't do that for this reason or
that reason but I noticed uh in recent
years people have done that in some way
um all right that should wrap up in a
moment here uh
yeah so oh yeah the question asked here
was do bigger brains have more
functional neurons are they just more
spread out
I don't know the answer that I'm
guessing there's a variation in both of
those things I know that there are
situations in which you get uh yeah I I
simply don't know they um
let's see
now the
Wes asks returning to a another
um
uh question would all whales speak the
same whale language
I suspect the answer is no and I think
it's even known that the answer is no
the only thing about whales that's weird
is that because they uh communicate
using sound in the ocean
and because you know in air for example
sound doesn't carry that far and still
uh maybe you can hear somebody I don't
know 100 feet away something like that
um but in the ocean in the deep ocean
where it's very still there are these
kind of wave guides so so normally in
sound it's you know you make a sound and
the sound waves are kind of going out in
all directions so if you go the the the
intensity of the sound goes down like
the square of the distance because
that's the area of the kind of shell of
where the sound gets to in all different
directions in the Deep potion there are
essentially wave guides that keep the
sound going in in one tube in the deep
in in just in the water in the ocean
that comes about because of the the
changes in the salt level and the
changes in the temperature and so on in
the in the ocean keeps the sound sort of
bouncing back and forth in this in this
kind of uh wave guide it's a little bit
similar to the way the fiber optics
keeps light you know bouncing back and
forth inside this little optical fiber
of glass or whatever and um so that
means that whale sounds can carry a long
way like across the ocean across the
Pacific Ocean same is true you know
that's the way people like in the US for
example on the east coast of the US one
knows that there's a hydrophone array
which is kind of listening for for
shipping in the Atlantic and uh the the
you know when if there's a ship that
goes through the stretch of Gibraltar if
it isn't a very special kind of ship you
can hear that from the hydrophone array
on the east coast of the US because the
in the deep ocean the sound from the
propeller of that ship sort of carries
all those thousands of miles and so for
whales similarly there is a uh you know
the the whale on one side of the Pacific
Ocean can be heard by whale on the other
side of the Pacific Ocean so you know
globalism probably came to the Wales a
lot earlier than it came to the humans
in the sense that the the number of
distinct sort of uh separate
conversations that can be happening is
is probably smaller because sort of the
each conversation carries further it's
um
but I I think I I vaguely remember that
there are distinct kind of I know there
are seasonal changes of the whale songs
I think there may be Regional ones as
well certainly among Birds there are
plenty of regional changes
um and that's uh uh you know there are
different dialects of uh uh different
songs sung by songbirds and things like
this and my guess is there are different
dialects of whale I don't know for sure
um and uh but as I say there's this
effect that sort of globalism came to
the Wales before it came to the humans
um
okay Wampus is noting that they had a
friend there's a bird that learned to
imitate their microwave alarm yep well
it's uh you know these neural Nets that
are in brains and that are in birds and
other brains
um they learn and they learn to uh uh
you know this is this is the interesting
feature of this sort of concept of
everyone that's that that sort of key to
our brains work
all right I think we should probably
um uh wrap up now and um
well uh this was this was uh fun for me
and uh you guys asking all kinds of
questions that um as I say
sometimes the the ones that sound
simplest are the ones that are uh most
tricky to answer but uh I've um uh it's
been interesting to to try and do some
of these here today
um all right well thanks for joining me
and um see you again another time
bye for now